- It has been, is it 20 years?
That you and your wife have been together?
- Something like that.
A long time.
- That's crazy.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Congratulations!
- [Jake] Thank you.
- That's hard to do.
But so wait-
- The beautiful Erin Payne made it up!
- When did y'all meet?
- So when I first moved to LA
she was a bartender at
The Cat and The Fiddle.
- Okay.
- And when I-
- Oh, I like The Cat and the Fiddle.
- It was a great place.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The original one too on Sunset.
And when I saw her I had that like moment
where I was like, "Oh
wow, like there she is!"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she did not have the same moment.
(everyone laughing)
And you know very quickly
when somebody's not feeling it back.
So I had like a, "Hey, what are you doing?
"How are you?"
And she's like, "What do
you want from the bar?"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- And so I started going to all her shifts
and I would just drink coffee.
- Oh my god.
- [Jake] And hang out.
- Some people call that stalking.
- Yeah, I stalked her.
(everyone laughing)
- I was like-
- 100%.
- I love that, okay.
- And so I went there, I hung out-
- And you went and got coffee?
- Yeah, because-
- At a bar?
- Well, it was an afternoon.
- Oh, okay.
- So she was a day bartender.
- You would've been frowned
upon to have maybe a vodka.
- Yeah, well also it's not
gonna work if I'm hitting on her
if I'm like a drunk.
- Yeah, that's true.
(audience laughing)
That's true.
This is a good thing.
- Yeah, so I sat there for all her shifts.
She did not notice me.
(Kelly laughing)
She didn't notice I was there.
- This is the best story.
- And then after about
two and a half months,
I finally had a moment where we talked.
And I had heard everything
she had said to other people.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- So I could connect on everything.
- This is totally stalking. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
Like your first date,
you were like,
you knew all this information.
- Not even the date. At the bar.
She's like, "How you doing?"
I'm like, "I've just
been training for a 5 K."
She's like, "I'm training for a 10 K."
I'm like, "What?"
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And then she's-
- That's crazy!
- I was like, "Yeah, I'm just
thinking about getting a dog.
"I love rescue dogs."
She's like, "I have a rescue dog."
I'm like-
(Kelly and audience laughing)
This is insane!
We should get outta here.
- Oh my god!
We should get married!
- We should get married!
(audience applauding)
- I love that though!
That you knew what you wanted.
- Yeah.
- And you went for it.
- That's awesome.
And 20 years, that's incredible.
(audience cheering)
Later that day,
the very funny Natasha Leggero
joined the conversation
and she was quick to reveal
the biggest ways her life
changed in the pandemic.
So you're normally that,
just kind of-
- Well, I'm just like-
- Just shove it.
- I just started to get frustrated
'cause I'm like, you know-
- 'Cause everything's filtered.
- Yes, and then during the pandemic,
I just couldn't keep up, you know.
It's like-
- Isn't the pandemic the time
that you would have all
the time in the world
to clean your closet? (laughs)
- Well, here's the thing.
(Kelly claps)
Here's my philosophy,
like husbands in the pandemic,
like look, Jake,
they all have these annoying hobbies.
Like Jake is now an amateur carpenter.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
My husband is like, he became a DJ.
A techno DJ in the pandemic.
- Wait, what?
- Horrifying.
My other friend is like
crocheting baseball caps.
- Is it horrifying?
(Jake laughing)
- Do you know what women
did in the pandemic?
Mothers?
They did laundry.
(Jake and audience laughing)
- And cooked like every meal.
- I know!
- Like every, yes.
And I was done.
- I'm over male hobbies, sorry Jake.
- Make a sandwich.
- Okay, I get it.
Look, I get it, I get it.
- I love that he became a techno DJ.
- Well then, you marry him.
- No, no, no!
When I say I love, I mean that is weird.
A weird thing.
- Well-
He already did it.
- Oh!
- And then he tried to reprise
it from like, 20 years ago.
- (laughs) Glory Days.
It's like Glory Days!
This is amazing!
There's a show in this. (laughs)
I love that.
So wait, you seem to collect toothbrushes.
So we just stalk you online.
- [Natasha] Okay, that is so embarrassing.
(Jake laughing)
- [Kelly] How many people
live at your house? (laughs)
My god.
- I do not collect toothbrushes.
But okay, so I have a-
- You do.
- (laughs) I have a, oh, that close up.
Okay, I have a podcast with my husband.
It's called The Endless Honeymoon Podcast.
And now I've decided instead
of getting couples therapy,
I just ambush him with my
issues during the taping.
- I love y'all.
- And-
- Okay.
- The last issue we had was
that he just uses my toothbrush.
And I'm like, "That is not okay."
- That is-
- He's like, "What?
"We're married."
So I brought it to the podcast.
- How does that translate?
What?
We're married so I can
use your toothbrush.
- I don't know.
(audience laughing)
He's just like-
Would you do that?
- Yes.
(audience laughing)
You're married!
- [Natasha] See what I mean?
It's disgusting.
- You don't lick someone's
like plaque on their teeth.
Like I just like, wait, what?
When you-
- Well, you rinse the
toothbrush afterwards.
It always starts clean!
- Yes, but god.
I feel like it's a very
dirty part of your mouth.
I'm so not into that.
- It's disgusting.
- What is this? A man thing?
- I don't know.
Well, 100% of the people-
You didn't chime in on my Instagram,
but everybody,
they shamed my husband so hard
that he went out and
bought 40 toothbrushes.
(everyone laughing)
(Kelly clapping)
And now I can't even find mine.
He's just like-
- Like lost in the abyss.
- He just got them everywhere.
But there is nothing worse
than going to grab like your toothbrush
and it's soaking wet.
So disgusting.
- Oh, it's intimate.
- [Kelly] No, no.
- Maybe the first three months of dating.
- Agreed, agreed.
It changes, it's a little gross.
- When you're still lying.
And you're like, "Yeah,
I'm totally into that."
And you're not.
That's the grossest thing ever.
It happened to me one time with my kid.
My kid used mine and didn't
know that you couldn't.
And I was like-
I don't even drink after people.
Like I don't like,
that's just gross.
Like people's saliva,
I'm just like (retches).
- Yeah.
- And when you put that wet
toothbrush in your mouth.
- Ugh.
- I literally almost vomited.
It was the grossest thing ever.
And it's my own child.
Sorry, River.
- Sorry, River. (laughs)
- Yeah, sorry,
but I don't want your nasty
mouth on my toothbrush.
Like especially a child.
They never brush their teeth.
- I know!
- They lie to you about it.
- I know.
- And then it's like how
much plaque was on there?